In the aftermath of a terrorist attack, we’re
always left asking the question: how could
anyone do this to another person?
While nothing can excuse their actions, maybe
psychology can help us understand the mind
of a terrorist.
Hello everyone, I’m Julian and this is DNews.
Terrorists are defined as a non-state group
that use violence against non-combatants for
political gain.
Their goal is to instill fear, and they achieve
it by targeting innocent people where they
feel safe.
This brutality is hard for us to comprehend,
so some may reason that a terrorist must be
mentally unstable in some way.
According to psychologist John Horgan, who
has written multiple books on the subject
of terrorism, psychologists have been trying
for over 40 years to identify the personality
disorder that defines a terrorist.
Are they psychopathic?
Are they anti-social?
Is there one defining characteristic that
unites them?
Unsatisfyingly, there is no one archetype
that every terrorist neatly conforms to.
There are risk factors and common threads
though.
Recruits are often motivated to join terrorist
groups because they feel alienated or disenfranchised,
or think they are the victims of a social
injustice.
They may be frustrated by other methods of
political change, want to take immediate action,
and don’t have a problem with violence against
the state.
Psychologist Steve Taylor from Leeds Beckett
University in the UK writes that it’s often
adolescent men who are drawn to this life,
because they’re at a point when they are
looking for a sense of belonging and purpose.
Once in the group, they develop an “us”
vs “them” mentality that makes it easy
to switch off empathy to the victims of their
attacks.
To them the deaths they cause are more akin
to destroying an object than ending a life.
Strangely though, sometimes they draw arbitrary
lines.
Horgan interviewed a former Irish Republican
Army bombing instructor who left the group
after the IRA murdered a pregnant officer.
Other people Horgan spoke to became disillusioned
when their group robbed a bank.
To them the killing was acceptable, but theft
was not.
Sometimes though, recruits are just bored
and looking for adventure, or they’re worried
about not leaving a lasting legacy.
People with little going for them in their
former lives are more likely to support the
actions of a group rather than form opinions
as an individual and voice dissent.
This groupthink can lead to further radicalization
of all the members.
Wanting to support and look out for each other
also becomes another motivation for killing.
Dr. Clark R. McCauley, director of the Solomon
Asch Center for Study of Ethnopolitical Conflict
at Bryn Mawr College, points out, modern militaries
use the same techniques by stripping soldiers
of individuality and placing the goals of
the group first.
Terrorists who do disagree with the group
will feel pressure to remain silent, because
they fear the consequences of voicing dissent.
Horgan points out they don’t have the option
to really leave either, as state governments
will offer little sympathy to deserters.
It’s tempting to boil down terrorists to
one trait or other.
The so-called "Islamic State," or ISIS, is
a group that’s stated goal is to create,
well, an islamic state, and so a facile conclusion
is their faith is to blame.
But according to political scientist Dr. Max
Abrahms, groups like that are quote, ”ignorant
people with respect to religion and they are
generally the newest members to the religion."
Horgan agrees with that assessment, saying
that young converts are more susceptible to
recruiters because they lack a deeper religious
knowledge that would help them reject extremist
arguments.
But Horgan insists that even if a perfect
model of a terrorist could be identified,
it wouldn’t be very useful.
After all you can’t arrest people just because
they have the potential to join violent extremists.
Instead he says we should be focusing on understanding
the paths that lead them there and giving
them options to get out.
Plenty of people who join up with radicals
eventually become disenchanted.
They realize that the group doesn’t really
serve their ideals, or isn’t the utopian
society the recruiters made it out to be.
Of course, Horgan and the people who study
terrorists have a tough job cut out for them.
Terrorist groups rely on fear tactics because
they are tiny minorities, and the people who
leave and are willing to talk to researchers
are an even smaller subset of that.
It’s a pressing problem that’s tough to
study, so hypotheses abound but there’s
very little in the way of actual data.
Once again, more research is needed.
Even though there are a lot of paths people
take to join groups like ISIS, for some reason
an unusually high number come from one town
in Belgium.
Lisette explains why over on Seeker Daily.
Whether you’ve been directly affected by
terrorism or not, we encourage you to find
a way to help.
Doing good anonymously is great, but if you
want to share what you’ve done or give others
ideas on how to get involved, we have a comments
section down there.
Let’s try and make the world a better place,
and I’ll see you next time on DNews.